has the symbiotes finally enter the
marvel cinematic universe well the
post-credits scene of spider-man no way
home has the answers of this franchise
changing question
let me just say one thing spoiler alert
okay now we're good let's start with
introducing what the symbiotes are the
klintar originally and better known as
the symbiotes are a species of inorganic
amorphous symbiotic extraterrestrials
created from the living abyss at the
beginning of the universe by the
primordial dark god called null
well the most famous of these is none
other than venom and he is as of now in
the main marvel comics continuity the
present god of the symbiotes if this
tickled your mind then do check out our
video on it it's in there in the channel
but this is somewhat different from what
we have seen in the recent venom movies
and this is especially important as this
is the particular venom that was
transported into the mcu following
doctor strange's spell and spider-man's
tampering with it we got to see it in
the post-credits scenes or rather the
mid-credits scenes of venom that there
be garnish where eddie and venom were
unknowingly teleported to the mcu
from their own timeline and venom
recognizing spidey on the news it was
one of those crossover that we all
wanted to see but sadly it didn't happen
it was just a brain teaser but is it
really this is where the fun starts and
where the future of spider-man and venom
in the mcu begins
following the end of the movie the
mid-credit scenes of spider-man norway
home finds eddie brock venom wearing a
mexico hat and drinking at a bar he's
talking to the bartender who has been
telling him about the kinds of
superheroes and villains that exist in
the mcu all about iron man who was a
billionaire flying a tin suit then a
green super powered hero who is the hulk
and also about thanos the alien who
likes to collect stones which confuses
eddie as the only alien he knows is
venom and the other symbiotes and they
don't like stones at all
brock then considers whether they should
pay this spider-man a visit in new york
the mid-credits scenes and spider-man on
their way home is linked to the
mid-credits scenes in venom let there be
carnage after seeing spider-man on the
way home his teleportation into the mcu
makes a little bit more sense and it's
all because of that strange spell though
it's unclear as to why bronx is there in
the first place after all he's never met
us peter parker it's not something we've
ever heard in any of the venom films he
doesn't even know a spider-man in his
universe let alone a guy named peter
parker this seems to be one massive plot
hole if you haven't seen the mid credit
scenes of what is venom that thereby
carnage
perhaps venom knows as he claims to have
80 billion light years of hive knowledge
spanning the multiverse in venom to
credit scenes it stands to reason that
his hive knowledge would contain
information about peter parker's status
as spider-man so perhaps venom was drawn
in by the spell and eddie was forced to
accompany him it is also maybe because
venom was about to share a tiny bit of
the hive knowledge with eddie when they
were automatically teleported into the
mcu as the multiverse also included toby
maguire's spider-man
and let me remind you that this
spider-man has fought a version of venom
before in his universe and it knew peter
parker was spider-man so it stands to
reason that the shared hive mind would
have that knowledge in it
so anyway the bartender wants brock to
settle the bill before he leaves for new
york to look for spider-man but at the
same time all venom wants to do a skinny
dip which isn't such a bad idea after a
few tequilas believe me
but before any of that can happen
strange's second spell from the end of
spider-man the way home kicks in sending
brock back to his universe but there is
one black smudge that was left behind in
this event and it starts moving which
means that yes a part of the venom
symbiote is effectively in the mcu for
good and with spider-man getting a fresh
start away from the confusing avengers
right now doctor strange and all that a
new fresh friendly neighborhood
spider-man is here along with venom
so now who is venom going to bond with
in the mcu and is he really the first
symbiote to be hinted in this franchise
well let's start with the first question
we know not of any eddie brock in the
mcu but we do have one very annoying
classmate of peter parker and that is
flash thompson and if you don't know
this then listen very carefully in the
comics venom has bonded with quite a
number of people but his favorite host
has always been either eddie or flash
thompson with flash as the host the
symbiote bonded with him becomes agent
venom and in other storylines he was
agent anti-venom perhaps this is where
the mcu is going with it and why venom
was seen only in the mid-grade scenes
which tell us that this entrance was to
leave a piece of the venom symbiote
behind and create a new storyline here
spiderman and venom always go hand in
hand
but is he really the first symbiote in
the mcu well clearly sony pitchers have
the final say on it because everything
venom is owned by them and if they come
to an agreement with disney then we
might just have a confirmation for two
other symbiotes that have been teased at
indirectly in the mcu and that is none
other than the first one the dark god
null who is the reason for the dead
celestial's head you know nowhere from
goddess of the galaxy and also another
symbiote would be his all-black neck
resort and where might we have seen that
look nowhere else than thor ragnarok
where do you think heller has all that
power from she is an asgardian god and a
goddess of death but her weapons of
choice and the way she transforms is
exactly how beings that born with the
all-black necrosaur would appear and yes
these weapons of hers are called
necrosaurs but that's enough speculation
for now
this movie sets things up for a new
trilogy for spider-man a future for many
of these characters and also saving the
mcu which was kind of down this year
with the current situation so there you
have it guys a spoiler-filled review for
the mid-credits scenes of spider-man no
way home we will discuss the second post
credit scenes in another video it's very
interesting hope you have enjoyed
watching this one anyway with that we
come to the end of it do hit that like
button for support and subscribe as well
to be a part of the mind cue family but
most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one
take care fam